bienvenue à paroles autochtone ici c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine la
question que j'ai reçus vient de jeu ce
qui me dit à qui appartient les maisons
des autochtones dans les communautés je
sais je sais que beaucoup de questions
tournent autour des maisons
d'appartenance de pouvoir passer des
loups et de pouvoir même avoir la
possibilité de vendre une maison
mais les maisons sur une réserve parce
que les communautés ya des communautés
qui sont des réserves des communautés
qui ne sont pas et les maisons sur une
réserve malheureusement sont liées à la
loi sur les indiens
c'est certain qu'on peut les louer on se
les louent souvent entre membres de
communautés disons que quelqu'un va aux
études à l'extérieur va louer sa maison
à quelqu'un de la communauté pour
l'année ou pour les deux années qui vont
s'en souvenir
des fois il ya des membres de
communautés qui vont pays pour faire
bâtir une maison à leur goût avec plus
de matériaux mais la terre de réserves
ça dit amateur qui est pour utilisation
fédéral est sur un territoire provincial
elle ne peut pas être vendu donc ça va
être souvent des espèces de forme de
location qui sont exclusives aux membres
de la communauté
parce que il faut pas oublier qu un non
autochtone ne peut pas venir vivre sur
une communauté il ya des maisons qui
sont alloués à des employés par exemple
qui eux peuvent venir vivre pour un
temps déterminé sur la communauté
pendant qu'ils y travaillent mais ils ne
peuvent pas acheter une maison et c'est
ce qui fait qu'on ne peut pas non plus
avoir de d'hypothèque
parce que pour avoir hypothéqué il faut
pouvoir saisir et pour pouvoir saisir
c'est malheureusement impossible
peut-être pas malheureusement mais c'est
impossible sur une réserve de saisir
quelqu'un parce que on est encore sous
la loi sur les indiens et on peut pas
saisir quelqu'un qui est mineure aux
yeux de la loi
il ya des communautés qui ne sont pas
des réserves qui elles construisent les
maisons les fonds suivent aussi dans le
fond les mêmes les mêmes règles de
bâtiments que dans des municipalités
ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent avec
ces maisons là mais ce ne sont pas des
réserves donc la maison en tant que tel
vaut souvent suivre le conseil de bande
vont être loués par le conseil de vente
mais le conseil demande voit aussi
souvent respectée la passation familial
c'est à dire que la mère ou la
grand-mère vaut louer ou donner la
maison après
on son décès à de sefyu à son garçon est
souvent ce sont des maisons qui vont
être même multigénérationnel multi
familiale dont il peut avoir une famille
de familles trois familles qui vont
vivre au sein de la maison mais qui peut
comprendre jusque là la question de
l'habitation dans les communautés
extrêmement difficile et extrêmement
coûteux aussi parce que si ta communauté
est proche d'une ville ou en milieu
loigné faire construire c'est ça ça
change énormément les coûts pour les
mêmes matériaux et là le territoire est
très limité aussi sur une réserve donc
ça fait souvent concorde très serré les
maisons j'espère que ça puis répondre
mais tu kong rock c'est une question
avec une très grande envergure qui est
dépend aussi de chacune des communautés
comment elle décide de faire son plan
d'urbanisme
j'espère que ça lui a répondu à ta
question j'espère que vous allez nous en
envoyer d'autres
et n'hésitez pas à partager ses vidéos
je vous souhaite une belle semaine